aussi loin que je me souvienne j'ai
toujours voulu être policier que mon
papa et du bush date de mm je t'enfonce
ma botte si loin dans le cul que tu y
lit pendant un tout petit pauvre merde
tous paient aujourd tout le monde
allez on y va est ce qu'un outil fait
son boulot de flic pouet pouet pouet
personne veut bosser ici mais si mais si
quelqu'un moi je suis devenu un vrai
flic maman m'a embauché c'est le seul
agent qui paye saronni je veux que tout
le monde se concentre sur l'arrestation
du producteur de maître jacques arbres
nouvelle breloque cette nouvelle drogue
est tout aussi dangereuse que festive et
ça s'appelle de la m chacun sait
sûrement l'oeuvre d'un grand esprit
criminel qui étudie aussi les motifs
porté par l'air et lander ses côtés
depuis le 17e siècle
j'ai mis morizet tout wikipédia au lieu
de me faire des amis
oh [ __ ] c'est trop bandant ça me met
mal à l'aise là laisse moi te montrer de
quoi je suis capable le togo mais la
sienne
[Musique]
ce travail et des boutons et dépravé je
vous dire une bonne chose c'est pas faux
vous c'était de venir
c'est pas faux vous êtes des monstres de
la nature et c'est pas faux c'est une
bande de mongolie a complètement
dégénéré
mais à quoi c'est tout ce que j'avais à
vous dire